it's no secret that much of popular
Greek mythology centers are under
Sandy's fellow Olympians which is why in
today's video we'll be discussing five
of the lesser-known gods and goddesses
the first 80 that we'll be discussing
today is Eris the goddess of discord and
strife now the way the ancient Greeks
would pronounce her name was Aries which
is actually not too dissimilar than the
way we would pronounce a God of War Ares
I'm sure there are some of you who may
be more familiar with her Roman
equivalent discordia and for those who
are unaware of what strife and discord
means it refers to anger bitterness
hostility and disagreement so you can
probably already start to imagine what
type of goddess Eris was her
misinterpretation of Eris was as a
daughter of Zeus and Hera Homer then
describes her as the sister and
companion of Ares at first she was only
a tiny thing but as she followed her
brother witnessing war and all the
things that came with it she grew so big
that when she walked the earth her head
could touch the heavens she would then
rain down bitterness and pain upon
mankind Hesed will never hand describes
her as the daughter of night meaning the
goddess NYX in Hesiod's interpretation
she's described as bring forth all the
struggles of mankind personified as her
children she gave birth to hardship
starvation pain battle war and Hesiod
lists the whole manner of horrid things
continues endlessly the most one untell
featuring eros is how she instigated the
Trojan War out of spite but that is
something we'll be discussing in more
detail when we do eventually cover the
Trojan War our second goal is one that
does bear some resemblance to Ares it is
the goddess of war conquest and
bloodlust enyo or anil homer regarded
enyo and eros is the same goddess but
there are several tales that make a
clear distinction between the two
deities and Nura is often seen following
Aires into battle but her relationship
with the goal of war varies from sister
to wife to even mother in some stories
there are some accounts of Ares going by
the title of any alias but this was also
the name of the son that he had with
Enyo a son that would later go on to
adopt his father's role as God of War
the exact role that any are played in
war was that of destruction she would
orchestrate the fall of cities following
Ares and his sons into battle she's
often depicted as a heavily armored
woman of a sword and shield similar to
her Roman counterpart below no Enya was
a fierce and bloodthirsty goddess and
almost definitely not one that you'd
wish to encounter
with all of the blood should aside from
our first two deities our third is
Asclepius or Asclepius the god of
medication rejuvenation and well-being
Asclepius was seen as the god of
physicians a skill that he would learn
at a very young age when he was born his
father Apollo to consider Centaur Chiron
who would teach in the art of medicine a
skill that he would then transfer to his
daughters who was seen as the
personification of medicine and healing
he was often depicted holding a rod or
staff that was encircled by a serpent
the escalade peon snake was named after
the god and it's a species of
non-venomous snake that became
associated with medicine and healing
unfortunately for circle appears he
would later be killed by Zeus when he
accepted payment to bring back the son
of Theseus from the dead the rattails
was later resurrected Asclepius in order
to avoid any conflict of Apollo
Asclepius was allowed to continue his
trade as long as he promised to never
resurrected their Davout permission as
well just on topic of death as gloomy as
it may sound that does take us to our
fourth deity which is actually a trio of
demigods that assume the role of
judgment within the underworld
Rhadamanthus mino-san
a across all wants the mortal sons of
zeus credited have established in law
and order on earth upon their deaths
they were granted the role of judges by
Hades and they would essentially
maintain law and order in his domain as
a trio they would judge the souls that
entered the underworld deciding if they
would be punished or sent to the Elysium
fields each charge would be assigned an
individual role a Akash was the guardian
of keys and would primarily judge them
in of Europe Rhadamanthus would rule
over the Elysium fields and was charged
with judging the men of Asia
Minos the once great king of Crete was
considered to be the third and final
vote if the first two judges could not
come to a decision then Minos vote was
final so our fifth and last day of
today's four seas the son of Pontus and
Gaia and one of the oldest gods of the
sea now four seas is a god that you may
have heard me mentioned but never in too
much detail and that's presume he's ever
mentioned in stories is as the father of
a creature or a deity depictions of
forces normally resemble an older man
with the lower half of a crab and
sometimes a tail of a fish for seasoned
his wife Sita may not feature in many
stories themselves and many of the most
iconic creatures and figures in Greek
mythology often attributed as their
children ranging from Medusa in the
Gorgons to Scylla an echidna this
naturally led to force he's been seen as
the god of large sea creatures so next
time you encounter a story of an
enormous monster of the sea and there's
a good
answer forces may have been the father I
hope you enjoyed this brief look at some
of the lesser-known deities there will
be another video including five more
next week as I promised the patrons a
list of ten which has now been split
into two videos of five so if there are
any deities you'd like to see in that
video then let me know in the comments
below